alright Wow this this better be good
after that right Wow
okay so registers have not been
investing too long I mean jeez I've been
investing a long time for me I've been
I've been I bought my first house on our
seventeen on our 28th so I'll be
investing just over a decade last year I
bought a castle ain't no money down
castle you know so so if you're
skeptical have unknowingly down yes it
works I think that's why they've got
three of us up I'm doing normally down
deals regularly residential we've got
free speakers all about no money down so
just out of just about curiosity if
you've ever bought a house about using
any of your own money just raise your
hand all right not not many like mostly
my students like ten people okay if
you'd like to buy house using none of em
any much hand that's why you're here all
right okay cool so so residential what
are some of the ways you can buy a house
about using any of your own money in
residential lease option okay cool what
else what's that a joint venture yeah
bridging maybe yeah angels what's going
on we okay I know how to find good
houses I'm really really really really
really good at finding houses but I
haven't got any money
is it possible is it just possible that
someone might have money but it sucks
finding deals yes or not so so so a way
to buy a house without using any of your
money would be well I'm really good at
finding houses you're really good at
saving money maybe I'll find the house
you put the money in and we'll do a
profit share that's called joint venture
it's just this this is very very very
easy what else a lease option yeah a
lease option okay so the lease option
would be you buy a house now and you
agree to pay for it later a bite now
I'll pay for it later now I'm not going
to long I mean I just got to focus on
one we didn't acute love lease option
agreements if I buy a holiday
now because people do this people walk
with a ball holiday on the credit card
or whatever and then agree to pay for
the holiday later the problem with that
is when you go to pay for it the
holidays gone so there's sometimes worn
off the holidays finish you still got to
pay for it that's a problem if you buy a
house now but you agree to pay for it
later while the time you go to pay for
it later what typically happens the
house price is due they tend to go up or
down
so again simple so you agree to buy a
house now but you agree to pay for it
later and there's a fair chance that by
the time you go to pay for it goes up
this is how I made most of my money in
property when I was 17 years old and I
had no money I just put offers on
properties on the condition that I'd pay
for it later
that's that's how I built my portfolio
and now I've got a very big portfolio
and and and when I went to pay for it
later that had gone up in value so
that's the first way you get paid second
way you get paid with lease option
agreement well how do you get paid when
you buy a house cash flow so you buy a
house and you you do what with it rent
it out and you get paid cash flow again
when you agree to buy a house now but
you say you'll pay for it later you get
the cash flow so I don't know why people
put deposits down I think it's what
we're taught by society we're taught to
go to school get a job save up money put
it in the bank buy a house pay off the
mortgage as quickly as possible and it's
the most ludicrous it's the most
ludicrous thing that you could do and
that's why people like Ranjan put these
put these networking events on and while
I come and speak and share at these
events because I we're tired of people
being told their whole life they have to
work hard saving money put it in the put
it in the bank so I'm gonna spend a few
minutes talking about lease option
agreements how you can find a lease
option agreement then we're gonna hold
more speakers and then we're gonna Duke
you in a bit so far how many in ammidon
okay can I keep going you're something
goes yeah all right thank you so how do
you find why would anyone want you to
have the house yeah you can have my
house
oh and you can pay me later that's no
problem why would anybody do that
negative equity yet maybe so what around
about 2006 the banks were giving out
100% mortgages I've got in a mad about
2008 so people had a big high mortgage
the value of the house might be 100 the
mortgage is 100 the value of the house
drops the mortgage is higher than the
value of the house then this person
wants to sell the house because they
have a change of circumstances maybe
they're moving abroad they split up with
their wife or for whatever reason they
want to sell and then they put it on the
market and they put it on for its drops
they put it on for the value that
they're over inflated price of a hundred
thousand and no one no one offers to buy
it it's too expensive I'll give you 80
thousand but the mortgage outstanding is
a hundred thousand does that make sense
yes so in that situation you become
stuck because your mortgage is higher
than your value so you're stuck and then
someone like me comes along and says
I'll give you the full asking price 100
even though it's not worth a hundred
even though it's been on it's been on
Rightmove for two years I'll give you a
hundred in seven years to give the
market chance to recover but right now
I'll take over your mortgage payments
and I'll be I'll basically become the
landlord from their point of view they
are then able to move on with their life
you then immediately benefit from the
cash flow and the cabbage depreciation
now the exciting thing is that's how I
started out ten years ago that's how I
started building my portfolio right now
on the line there are hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of people that are
stuck in this situation whereby they've
got negative equity
there are hundreds and if we had time
I'd jump online right now I would find
some I would phone them and I would
secure a deal in front of you that's how
good I am and that
how many they are that are stuck and
this is what I do idea on YouTube idea
all the time I just if you've been to my
this is it I just go online find these
people that are stuck and say hey I'll
give you the I'll give you I'll give you
the I'll give you the price you want but
I'll pay on my terms or I'll give the
price I want but I'll pay on your terms
that's it that's the lease option
agreement buy it now
pay for it later so following them
people in negative equity you can find
them on online hundreds of them how do
you speak to them again I would just use
that alone I would say I can give you a
hundred percent of the value but I'll
pay on my terms
or I can give you payment on your terms
but eighty percent of the price not only
does this work in England Scotland
they're also a little different and all
the Scots are like oh my gosh we cannot
do this you can you can just do it in
Middlesbrough okay
but then I wouldn't be able to manage it
though you shouldn't manage it in the
first place
because that's not passive income
passive income is when you when you buy
a property and you use a management
company turns out you can do this in
England you can do it in many parts of
the UK but you can do some many parts of
the world as well I went to an airport
last year I got my phone out on a
Facebook live literally and said what
country do you want me to go to and I'll
go right now and I'll buy a house about
using any my own money because I know
how many different strategies there are
to buy houses about use only your own
money and they picked in New York I went
to New York in America secure a property
using exactly what I just said
secured a no-money-down lease option
agreement in America documented the
whole thing for free on YouTube just
because I enjoy exposing the myths of
the banks the education systems and the
schools that teach get a job work hard
healthful mortgage that sucks so I'm
glad you're here thanks for listening
look for the Q&A and if you want to self
if me later on I'm around or you might
have chat I'll stick around and thanks
for having me run John in the team thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]